hey guys my name is Jess McDowell today
it's that the tape of July and you're
watching games buggies it's probably not
news to you that a lot of people buy
halo games but regardless Microsoft have
announced today that the Halo series has
the past 65 million units sold the
sci-fi shooter series debuted in 2001
with halo combat evolved on the original
xbox back in October of last year the
series had hit a milestone of 16 million
games sold so it seems quite a few of
you picked up halo the master chief
collection between then and now a better
or worse hello is also featured in a
number of Xbox one system bundles so
that's also likely to have helped it
along the next century in the series
halo 5 Guardians is due out in October
the co-creator of Assassin's Creed Jade
Raymond has moved to EA to help with the
development of this Star Wars title
Raymond has founded a new EA studio
called motive and will be working with
visceral games on the upcoming Star Wars
game with former Uncharted series writer
Amy Hennig Raymond has also suggested
the studio may have a hand in developing
Mass Effect Andromeda explaining that
motive will work in close quarters with
the Bioware team in addition she said
that the studio will also be working on
entirely new IP and taking on some
amazing projects Raymond left Ubisoft in
October 2014 after 10 years with the
company and called her decision to leave
quote one of the hardest decisions of my
career xbox and Phil Spencer has
answered a range of fan questions on
Twitter addressing the specifics of the
xbox one's backward compatibility
semenza has said that there are some
challenges both technical and otherwise
affecting which xbox 360 games can make
their way to xbox one through the
emulation process among those Spencer
noted that racing games are difficult to
bring over due to logos and music
licensing issues but the plan is to
quote support backwards compatibility
completely he hinted
at first party games like the fable
trilogy are likely to make their way
over and their team are currently
addressing how to potentially include
DLC and space games the feature is been
testing for Xbox preview members at the
moment and is due to roll out to
everyone this fall let me know down in
the comments if you'll be trying out the
xbox one's backwards compatibility
feature you can head the game spot where
we've got the full HD Suicide Squad
trailer and some touching or watch a
tribute that is everything I have for
your Monday let me know what you cared
about today and I'll catch again the
more